so cute so standing like a foot away
from a lion it was the most amazing
experience making marrow
yeshua i'm gonna take five puppies home
with me today from this and it went roar
i'm ew mcgregor and i play obi-wan
kenobi in the new series on disney plus
and i'm on buzzfeed today playing with
puppies bring in the puppies
hello
[Music]
there wasn't a pitch as such because
i wasn't like offered the they didn't
give me send me a script and say you
know would you play obi-wan kenobi
[Laughter]
i was asked if i would play
obi-wan kenobi in every single interview
that i ever did for years i was asked
would you play
would you do the sequel to trainspotting
and would you play obi-wan kenobi again
and i started saying yes to both so i
made the
train spot in sequel
i just would say yes i want to play
obi-wan kenobi again and then disney
called me in and said look is it true
you're saying that you'd play obi-wan
again is it true and i said yes let's
see if there's a good story between
not really we hadn't seen each other a
lot over the years and the best thing
about it was that it led to this moment
playing with the puppies right now
i've got lots of lovely memories of it
they're kind of odd because so much of
it wasn't
so much of it wasn't there it was a lot
of green screen
and blue screen and
come on then come on there what was the
question favorite moments um
i don't know why i
just can't take it
it was pretty amazing to put on the
clothes again to feel um to to dress as
obi-wan kenobi again after so long was
pretty amazing yeah the lights we had a
lot of lightsaber training
yes i'm going to take five puppies home
with me today from this experience
it was the most amazing experience
making monroe you know doing the the
musical sequences during the time
remember never forget doing the tango
where i'm all upset and i'm got a big
coat and i walk down and all the dancers
are doing the tango and i walk through
them and the camera was on the crane and
the crane had to go out the door of the
studio because it was such a massive
shot and they kept pushing the crane
back and back and back till it was
outside the studio it was just the most
amazing experience the music and the
recording of the music and the playing
with nicole and all those great actors
it was just amazing
[Music]
this show was oh lovely
yes you lovely little dog it was the
same i just watched all this i had
soaked myself back into the star wars
world by watching all the movies by
listening to alec guinness interviews by
watching i had alec guinness dialogue
from a new hope just on a sound file
just all his lines are very nice ah
yes fitness did a lot of fitness
training because you know those fight
sequences are really they're really hard
to do and it takes sometimes weeks to
shoot a fight so i'm 50 years old now 51
years old now so i had to get super fit
before we started it
[Music]
so fast
i mean big fish i got to i did a scene
with elephants and i got to lean against
an elephant i got to stand in the middle
of a
big globe while the motorcycles went
around my head i got to stand in front
of a real lion and the lady the lion
trainer said she said to me when i went
on okay just stay still don't make any
sudden movements and don't do anything
that might annoy the lion and i went
okay so i was standing like a foot away
from a lion she had a riding crop that
was she held backwards she had the she
had the heavy end of it over there she
was holding the thin end of it and when
tim burton said action she bopped the
lion on the head with the heavy end of
the crop
and it went roar and i thought she told
me not to annoy it but she just bumped
it in the head
i'd like to play
crazy aren't they i mean i don't know it
have to be my character from the
original maybe i play that green
character harrison ford shoots in the
bar at the beginning
maybe i play him
so cute
i love working with deborah she's the
most amazing director talent she's so
good with the actors she's so good with
the uh knowing the star wars world
inside out yeshua no we're lucky to have
her as our director for all of them so
her sort of vision goes through the
whole series which is really cool it
would have been different i think if
we'd had a different director for each
episode and as it is like one singular
story that we that we sort of start from
start to finish it was great that is her
it's her vision throughout hi guys
i've been doing it a long time i can't
remember there's some characters you
love to hate i think the first character
i ever played in shallow grave was such
an he's such a dick you know that it was
fun to see him interact with my priest
character from them angels and demons oh
easy it's been such a joy to be with
these puppies today they are all rescue
dogs a vanderpump rescue here in l.a and
they're all available for adoption so if
you've got a nice home
to give these puppies that would be
great to give them a ring and our show
um obi-wan kenobi on disney plus and i
hope you all enjoy it very much
cheers hello little [ __ ] dog oh my
god
oh with your little sausages
[Music]
you